that we're driving to the end of the
road to the Napali coast line
some of the most
in scenery around here coming up
famous Bali Hai
would be surprised if you saw a dinosaur
or
it's coming right out of these crazy
so just got back from a two-hour
training ride in the pouring rain out
here so I feel like I've been mountain
biking anyway
that's what happens on the North Shore
lots of rain but beautiful right a day
Monday night
hot away Jason Rebecca stuff on our face
eating ice he does gorging good secret
weapon to to turn load so right now
we're day and a half away what's on your
mind
I'm tired and getting up at 4 o'clock
every morning the best
three mornings and I'm just ready to get
the show on the road any anything like
concerns we've been talking about all
the logistics logistics are crazy
bring it bike boxes on the planes some
of the planes will let us walk our bikes
on but worried about the flights getting
damaged how do we bring the bike boxes
from so you know as much as the physical
just got that Town Road dog that's why
it's called a challenge because the
logistics of it is actually the
challenge and it's been keeping our mind
off of actually what we're gonna have to
endure over the next five days
we're gonna pick out in the next two
days I'm gonna see how you see how fat I
can get for the six pitches soul is to
say how much weight he can gain in the
next two days I asked her this morning
it is pregnant because everybody came
out of his condo and look like it a baby
hide in the stomach but our goal is to
eat as much as we can stuff ourselves
you know clean good foods but eat a ton
because this events gonna all be about
nutrition so thank you for coming along
beautiful on la Hawaii right now we're
two days away less than 48 hours
scoping out the swim course
trying to figure out well dog and I
decided without the race today so - you
want to start we get started at dusk and
go through the night the way these waves
are kicking we might as what to start
today no this Bay was totally flat the
other day now we're looking at we're
hearing it's something about a North
swell coming in so we're a little
concerned it just means that you know
you're gonna have to you have to get
past the break yeah you know you can't
swim in close to shore if it's like this
so there's it's all good everything's
gonna work out perfect because you know
why it's everything we're getting ready
to have our Last Supper and our awesome
friend Rebecca cooked us vegetarian
lasagna and quinoa loaf quinoa low rich
ready were packed reading dinner at like
4:00 in the afternoon
yeah feels weird huh obviously that
clock is a hard day like packing up
boxes and getting organized trying to
make sure everything is in a certain
place so we can find what we need when
we need it
no nutrition during out today alright 5
o'clock we just by 5:00 hammered
gigantic quinoa loaf and some vegan
lasagna with tofu and spinach so rolled
out here at our dinner table
a little bit about epic five and maybe
like over what our fears are what we're
thinking about and I was just telling
them that I really done I have no fear
like I I'm really excited
checking the Twitter feed and just
getting like so much support from people
out there I don't know nervous nervous
and James Gilbert at sandbox James my
breath kids big props to James squadra
so that's cool we got we got the vitamin
shot thanks for everything buddy now in
Santa Monica and in Redondo Beach Bike
Works grant Vern Keith all you guys
thanks for making this possible god I'm
just amazed and we have over seventeen
sponsors that came up and supported us
and through down to make this thing
possible
how about Brett and Morgan Zen triathlon
that's right Morgan's butt off totally
hook us up with the with the live update
page geeking set out on the tech front
that's right
so we can share the experience you're
gonna go to your word appreciate that
making it possible for all you guys out
there to go to WWF pick five calm /live
they'll be able to track us live for the
next five days that's slash forward
slash
that's how about Alberta coffees in
Hawaii
how about Albert coffees of Hawaii and
Molokai hey guys need a place to stay we
would love to have you come stay with us
at our house
epic you guys really are truly epic I
mean you know it takes a lot for rich
and I to train for something like this
but this is a whole team effort you guys
are all on our team tropical smoothie
back home ultimate ro burger Wendy
you're an angel everybody back home in
Kona that's supporting us I know you
guys are all waiting for us at the king
cam Hotel chillin at the pool
what word out here battling it but um
this is all for you anyway guys thanks a
lot
check in with you later bye 5 epic 5
what's going down peace